اثاره الانسحاب الروسي من خرسان لم تختفي
منحنايا المدينه كما من نفوس اهلها الذين
سيق العشرات منهم الى غرف التعذيب غرف
الرعب الصغيره التي عرضت صورها صحيفه ديلي
تلغراف خصصت اساسا لاستجواب الجنود
الاوكرانيين المعتقلين هذه الغرف استقبلت
كذلك مئات سكان المشكوك بامرهم اي
المتهمين بنقل معلومات الى الجيش
الاوكراني عن مواقع القوات الروسيه
وتحركاتها في خرسان ورغم صعوبه استحضار
ذكريات ايام الاعتقال سرد الجندي مكسين
احد الاسرى السابقين اساليب التعذيب
المتعدده والمتجدده التي اعتمدها الروس
بعد دخولهم عمليه استجواب استغرقت اكثر من
ثلاثه اسابيع واستخدمت خلالها الاسلاك
والانابيب المعدنيه والهيراوات الخشبيه
للضرب وتكثير العظام
غير ان اصوات المعتقلين والامهم كانت تعلو
اكثر حين استخدام الصعق بالكهرباء لتصنع
بين جدران الزنازين وفقما قاله الجندي
الاوكراني للتلغراف فالجنود الروس كانوا
يعلقون حلقات معدنيه باذان المعتقلين
موصوله على جهاز الصعق ثم يقومون بضربهم
بالتيار الكهربائي اكثر من 800 و69 شخصا
اعتقلوا في خرسان منذ دخول القوات الروسيه
اليها قبل التسعه اشهر لكنها 480 شخصا
منهم فقط اطلق سراحهم دون معرفه مكان او
مصير المتبقين في المقابر الجماعيه او تم
نقلهم لمناطق تخضع للسيطره الروسيه اما
الجثث المعثور عليها حتى اللحظه والتي
بينت اثار التعذيب فقدرت بثلاث 63 زفه